[музика]
звинувачуйте саме Україну в тому що ця
війна триває на це щонайменше цинічно і
нечесно і росіяни це військові злочинець
це окупанти мародери грабіжники
гвалтівники які прийшли в якій влізли в
нашу країну для того щоб вона закінчити
вбивати про яку російську культуру Зараз
можна говорити
уїзду з Європи на синьо-жовта Я не хочу
завтра залишитися без держави і щоранку
як ти пишеш гарно в Фейсбуці ми
прокидаємося на день ближче до перемоги
ми так росіянин
Сергій 8 місяць повномасштабною війни
Росії проти України
демократичний світ підтримує Україну
постачає зброю нарешті І раптом цвіти
маска на кшталт припинити війну віддати
Крим Росії Україні найти в НАТО при
цьому він підводить риску Що Він
підтримує Україну Що це Та є безношення
твій та маска тому що ну Маск має цю
здатність час від часу писати дурниці
Мені здається що повторювати дурниці це
шкодити собі тому я би сильно На цьому
не акцентував тут інша річ наш цікава
якщо ти пам'ятаєш він десь нещодавно
згадував що він
є частиною аудиторії решето дещо він
дивиться новини від Рашу туди і Мені
здається це оце от страшенно-показова
річ і вона визначальному Можливо в цьому
всьому тому що далі в світі є частина
політичного економічного і став
більш-менту і культурного мабуть люди
які далі дивляться на нашу війну через
російську тобто далі сприймають
російські наративи як частину
незаангажованої інформації як частину
інформації яку в якій можна довіряти
наскільки пам'ятаю Маск Саме так і
сказав що там багато дурниць ваша туди
але є і цікаві факти є цікаві новини і
якщо він там може для себе щось
знаходити чому варто довіряти Ну то не
дивно що час від часу в ньому можуть
переживатися такі як ти виплески
виплески дурощів інакше це не назвеш
тому що очевидно що що ця інформація яка
абсолютно не корулюється з реальністю це
якась паралельна реальність і довіряти
їй керуватися нею ну це значить я
абсолютно нічого не розуміти в цій війні
дійсно на восьмому місяці збройного
протистояння далі боятися
повномасштабної війни така власне що що
відбувається ці вісім місяців знищення
знищені міста знищена попасность
Северодонецьк Маріуполь в
братські поховання масові поховання
масові військової злочини це
неповноцінна війна тобто що тут ще
боятися
насправді Це свідчить про те що люди не
зовсім розуміють і можуть відбувається
далі далі реагують скоріше на весь і
погрози з боку російського керівництва а
не на реальний стан речей на фронті але
Маск не один як складаються твої
стосунки з німецькими літераторами
інтелігенцією Я згадую зараз той лист
який вони написали що треба припинити
постачати зброю в Україні треба миритися
з Росією
ну Послухай є різні опції чудово
розумієш що німецьке суспільство воно
доволі неоднорідне і попри те що на мій
суб'єктивний погляд до в основному німці
підтримують Україну в цій війні і на
політичному рівні на суспільному рівні
ясна річ що є частина
в німецькому суспільстві громадяни які
далі вважають що є Ця страшна
Непереможна Росія і краще не дратувати
тому що коли її роздратуєш то буде
набагато гірше і тому краще
запропонувати Україні таку От
капітуляцію
маскуючи під
мирні ідеї і ідеї пацифізму насправді це
пропозиція капітуляція тобто здатися на
відкупку окупантам і так буде всім
спокійніше різні настрої є Просто мені
здається що Це доволі таки маргінальні
настрій і в німецькому суспільстві
навряд чи Навряд чи вони тут провалюють
те що вони є Ну та вони є безперечно і
мені здається що тут дуже важливо дуже
важливо все-таки якось
пояснювати свою позицію і пояснювати
власне чого ми опираємося чому Ми не
здаємося от зараз низка концертів
відбувається твоїх в Німеччині ти
учасник літературних фестивалів читань
які тези саме зараз ти залишаєш тут в
Німеччині аудиторії
тезу про те що українці
боронилися будуть боронитися щоб ми
боремося ми боремося за свою землю ми
говоримо за свою свободу за своє
майбутнє що ми цю війну не починали і
нам вона звичайно ж 100 років не
потрібна і звинувачувати саме Україну в
тому що ця війна триває ну це щонайменше
цинічно і нечесно і з наш крім того
насправді мені дуже важливо це
стосується не лише Німеччини але лише
німецьку аудиторії ми останнім часом
виступали у Польщі і в Чехії і в Австрії
і в країнах Балтії подякувати тим людям
які всі ці місяці допомагають Україні а
це справді дуже велика підтримка і на
рівні політичному і на рівні суспільному
знову ж таки повторюся ми з перших
тижнів там от в Україні особливо на
сході України відчувалося підтримку
дуже багато людей
відгукувались дуже багато людей
передавали якусь гуманітарну допомогу
дуже багато людей
намагалися говорити про ситуацію в
Україні це старшина важливо тим не менш
заборона концерту жадана і собак в
Мілані І от зараз в Гамбурзі заборонили
концерт скрипки
аргументація своя скрипка фашист жаданий
собака збирають гроші цю неможливо я я
не можу укоментувати ситуацію з Олегом
тому що я не знаю яка там що ще там було
в нашому випадку це скоріше скоріше
виняток Це скоріше Я знову ж таки
дивна непослідовна і двозначна позиція
організаторів які просто перелякалися
реакції і якихось відвідувачів тому
насправді навряд чи це система і навряд
чи це
свідчить про в якісь настрої в
суспільстві скоріше навпаки ми де не
їздили бачили активну підтримку нас з
боку організаторів власників клубів там
де ми виступали
якраз було дуже позитивне ставлення до
України тому я би на це не зважав я би
концентрувався і акцентував скоріше на
тих позитивних моментах на елементах
підтримки тому що подивився 8 місяць
війни
а підтримки не стає менше і справді
їздячи Європи на синьо-жовте навіть тут
в Києві сьогодні що вулиці бачу багато
українських прапорів підтримка в Європі
це і твої благодійні концерти це люди
які перераховують кошти це На що вони
йдуть якщо можна спитати
Та я ж насправді звітую на що я витрачаю
передусім Ми купуємо зараз багато
автівок для різних підрозділів купуємо
спорядження для військових е-е купуємо
техніку на яка не є військова ясна річ
скажімо тепловізори і дороги себто це те
що потрібно військовим щоденно це те що
потрібно різним підрозділам
тебе не бентежить що це робиш ти а не
держава ну Держава це теж робить я ж
не є противником своєї держави
громадянин у своїй державі і хочу
допомагати Я хочу щоб вона утвердилася і
перемогла цю війні Я не хочу завтра
залишитися без держави тому я ясна річ
що можу критикувати якісь дії влади але
критикувати все поспіль Мені здається це
просто на конструктивно А що ти
критикуєш ну і Послухай коли українська
влада забуває що під час війни теж не
слід порушувати закони теж не слід
обмежувати якісь Свободи Це мабуть не
дуже добре скажімо Ти мабуть слідкували
за цією ситуацією з нашими єдиним
марафоном коли звідти викинули деякі
телеканали Мені здається це не зовсім
правильно Мені здається це м'яко кажучи
обмеження обмеження певних демократичних
Свободи проти цього виступав
але з іншого боку вона ж мені не зовсім
подобається і здається не зовсім доречно
наша українська критиканство коли
критикуються в принципі будь-що
Мені здається що все-таки слід зараз
думати трішки стратегічніше але Свобода
слова то важливо важливо що не слід
заплющувати очі коли воно порушується
найближчим часом в Німеччині має вийти
твоя книжка
вже вийшло небо над Харкова її Як ти сам
сказав склали твої друзі зібравши той
дописи соцмереж А ти як поет письменник
щось за цей час писав Так писав не так
багато звичайно тому що Ну по-перше і
емоційний стан був трішки інший та і в в
принципі трішки було недописання але та
щось писалося ми з музикантами зробили
кілька пісень якісь вірші писалось якісь
прозові тексти Ну просто зараз не так
важливо
поет письменник музикант волонтер Це
правильне слово до для описання але воно
мабуть зараз не зовсім не зовсім само
себе характеризує Мені здається сьогодні
саме поняття волонтерство однозначно
втратило свої якесь початкове значення
сьогодні всі фактично волонтери всі хто
працює на Україну всі її по своєму
волонтерами підприємець який сьогодні не
закрив свій бізнес а далі ним займається
і платить податки Мені теж по своєму
волонтер
А я продовжуючи це питання А ким ти
зараз як Сергій Жадан найбільше
залишаєшся та Я громадянин України який
хоче перемога своєї країни Мені здається
це сьогодні найважливіше Нещодавно ти
дискутував з філософом Вахтангом
кибуладзе про те якими ми вийдемо з цієї
війни А яким ти з ним вийдеш
Мені важко сказати тому що в якось рани
поки що рефлексувати І рано поки що
усвідомлювати що з нами усіма сталося за
ці місяці що відбулося я старі чи ми
виходимо іншими
Іноді ці зміни позитивні Мені здається
не дуже Мені здається всі страшному
стресі
всі доволі втомлені для когось цей стрес
Я думаю що далі буде тривати але не так
чи інакше Мені здається та українці
показали що вони доволі сильні що ми
доволі сильні та і Що так чи інакше ми
вийдемо Ми вийдемо переможцями цієї
ситуації Я чесно кажучи це вірю Я бачу
для цього передумови Ну ти трошки ще й
пророк був в своїх творах але ну от Саме
зараз в тебе які відчуття коли ми
вийдемо Ми Слухай боюсь про це говорити
Тобто я не хочу заручити не хочу
загадувати Мені здається що українці все
роблять правильно Ми не здаємося ми не
поступаємося ми тримаємося один одного
Ми тримаємо своїх цінностей Ну в
принципі це те що ми можемо робити ми
апелюємо до світу нагадуючи світові що
це війна ця війна вона не стосується
лише України Росії це справді це великий
надлам якийсь стався
цілому світі свій
світовій безпеці і світовому порядку і
ясна річ що сьогодні не можна просто
ігнорувати те що відбувається в Україні
не можна просто Робити вигляд що це
якийсь локальний в Східноєвропейський
конфлікт
Сергій незважаючи на те що ти постійно в
роз'їздах в тебе маса концертів маса
виступів за межами Харкова Львів Київ в
Європі все одно Ти залишаєшся в Харкові
це насправді дуже мужній крок чому чому
що тут мушнього
це нормально залишитися в місті де ти
живеш Люди рятуються від війни і ну
Послухай Ну я ж теж
рятує свою скажімо в своєму помешканні
та чи там от е-е якихось підвалах перші
тижні Насправді Я би не не не не
реалізував людей які залишились тому що
це свідомий був вибір і не слід цьому
бачити геройство і так само не слід
бачити відсутність героїзму людей в діях
людей мотивації людей які поїхали свого
часу підозрів Можливо вони зробили
навіть мудріше ніж ті хто залишився ніж
Дехто з тих хто залишився тому що коли
Ти залишаєшся і ти маєш Чим зайнятися і
ти є ефективним на своєму місці ну це
одна річ ін коли ти просто лишається щоб
сидіти під обстрілами Я чесно кажучи не
зовсім бачу
логіку і конструктив таких діях тому
мені здається воно тут ті люди які
залишалися для того щоб працювати
свідомий і у свої якісь усвідомлений
вибір був і ну залишилося залишилося
але теж відчуваєш свою корисність з
огляду на те скільки Ну я розумію що
якби я
Ну що я би міг бути менш корисним Якби я
кудись виїхати ми з друзями справді щось
робимо у місті і в нас багато роботи і
ця робота і нам і тим з кимось
співпрацюємо видається важливою твоя
цитата Мистецтво - це не лише про митців
це великою мірою про публіку про
аудиторію себто громаду яка здатна
об'єднуватися довкола цінностей візі Та
переконань Яка твоя аудиторія зараз вона
змінилася вона не змінилася ні ні це ті
люди які до війни нас слухали які
приходили і підтримали українські
мистецькі проекти які читали українські
книжки слухали українську музику
дивилися українське кіно Тобто це
пасіонарна активна публіка вона навіть
публіка слова погане аудиторія Можливо
так е-е
громадяни які мають активну позицію і
політичної культурною які в більшості та
своєї от з початком цієї нової фази
війни включилися в діяльність хтось
пішов
на фронт хтось почав волонтерити
зазвичай ці люди які знайшли себе в цій
війні не виявилися загубленими і
дезорієнтованими
на тлі того що це люди які підтримують
українську культуру
твоя позиція щодо того що зараз
відбувається в Україні з російською
культурою книговиданням Скажімо так
звісно українці мають вирішувати Що з
цим робити відмовлятися повністю
переосмислювати потім вирішувати ти про
це вже думав що ми в Харкові за ці 8
місяців
зробили вже цілу низку якихось дискусій
круглих столів ввечерів де все це
публічно обговорило зокрема антитети
згадували цю нашу зустріч з Вахтангом і
це все було в межах фестивалю який
називається п'ятий Харків ми його робили
з харківським літературним музеєм три
дні дискусії читання в концерті в Мені
здається що цікава акція вийшла і велика
кількість публіка саме ті публіки по
якому ти говоримо і там зокрема ми і про
це говорили про цей проросійський
контекст інформаційний контекст
культурний контекст проросійської
присутність нашого інформаційному
культурному просторі про те що власне з
цим буде як це все буде трансформуватися
як це все буде видозмінюватись А те що
це буде змінюватися ну для мене очевидно
Росії в Україні відверто забагато
але щось можна залишати чи чи ми зараз
відмовляємося від усього ми зараз
говоримо про те що Росія - це країна яка
нас хоче знищити яка не баче нашого
існування от вони в принципі на
державному рівні на Громадському рівні
на рівні своїх якихось спікерів говорить
про те що вони не бачать нашого
існування А ми при цьому далі дискутуємо
про те чи ми хочемо залишити що оці з
вікні присутності чи не хочемо Мені
здається занадто
занадто ліберальна позиція Мені здається
що
російською присутність в Україні треба
ставити на таку тривалу серйозну паузу
От після того як завершиться війна після
того як ми повернемося контроль над цими
кордонами після того як з боку Росії
буде якась рефлексія на те що відбулося
буде якась хоча би подобазна
покаяння чи усвідомлення того що вони
зараз чинять з нами Та ну тоді можливо
можна буде починати спроби якогось
діалогу до того пускаю росіяни це
військові злочинців це окупанти мародери
грабіжники гвалтівники які прийшли в
якій влізли в нашу країну для того щоб
вона знищувати і вбивати про яку
російську культуру Зараз можна говорити
фільтруєш
своїх візовій на заходах в Європі на
якій Тебе запрошують Та я не знаю що
оскільки це справді така дуже
двозначна теми намагаюсь просто нікуди
не їздити якщо якщо беру участь то це
або якісь наші
сольні концерти Та бо якісь проекти
якісь фестиваль іде напевно не буде
якихось
представників російської культури тому
що часто Ти десь не перепитаєш десь не
узгодиш і потім ти бачиш Ти вже в
компанію якихось російських авторів і
все це відбувається Просто без твого
відома поза твоєю поза тим щоб тебе
запитали поза тим щоб з тобою Це все
було насправді Це доволі противно тому
що це свідчить про те що організатори
таких речей його не просто не розуміють
що відбувається
а все відслідкувати насправді дуже важко
коли тебе просять скажімо там для
публікації якийсь вірш А потім
виявляється що він в журналі де в якийсь
дослідження протистоєвського ну це
щонайменше
просто викликає якесь непорозуміння
цілком
тим не менш не можу не запитати бо зараз
в Німеччині політично дуже активізується
теза про те що треба приймати ухилянтів
від Російської мобілізації як біженців
та як до цього ставишся Ну слухай я я би
не давав якихось порад скажімо владі
Німеччини що робити Я думаю хай саме
розбирається якось з мого боку це можуть
бути не зовсім коректно в мене ці люди
не викликають жодної якоїсь симпатії
жодної Кості в принципі якось співчуття
тому що великої міри Я дивлюся що
відбувається вони протестують не проти
війни з України вони не проти цієї
окупації Вони проти своєї участі в цій
війні насправді це такі пристосуванство
в більшості випадках і
не знаю крім огиди нічого не викликає
тобто 7 місяців Вони сиділи і все
влаштовувалося місяців Ніхто не виходив
на вулиці не виступав 7 місяців вони
дозволяли собі щось коментувати в
соціальних мережах і тут раптом коли це
почало торкатися безпосередньо їх
Вони почали тікати і почали видавати
себе за жертви режим це їхній режим вони
його вигодовували вони Фактично це є
режим створили вони витравили цього
колективного Путіна тому якось ще їм
співчувати ну учасника чи в мене емпатії
не вистачає
Зараз ми поки готувалися до інтерв'ю
пішли новини про те що у бік України в
Росії рухається ядерний потяг не
виключено що на ньому
ядерні
боєприпаси ти боїшся ядерної війни
Ну я боюся Послухай боюсь за інших людей
за близьких собі людей Я боюсь в
принципі за людей які живуть в Україні
безперечно Коли ти думаєш чим це може
завершитися це
жодних якихось
позитивних думок не викликають Я розумію
що це викликає лише тривогу і
напруженість але що стосується Ну там
особисто мене Ну Послухай Ну якось в
Харкові за ці місяці звикли Ну не сильно
не сильно рефлексувати з приводу
майбутнього
достатньо вибудувати план собі до ранку
там Скажімо так переночувати пережити цю
ніч Прокинутися живим здоровим і зранку
щось далі починати робити а якось думати
стратегічно планувати своє майбутнє на
тиждень чи на місяць ну це занадто
велика розкіш
з війною з'являються такі певний
фаталізм Він можливо не дуже здоровий І
не дуже позитивний але ну Послухай коли
ти бачиш щоденні обстріли коли ти бачиш
що відбувається
зрозуміло що це Міняє Міняє оптику міняє
саме відчуття якогось перспективи
відчуття майбутнього як такого
я старий що ми всі вже не такі як були
до 24 лютого
ми всі не такі які були на 24 лютого
ти
проводиш масу заходів як ти відновлюєшся
Я не знаю
якісь природний
якийсь цикл достатньо Там просто
відіспатися де та й все але насправді Я
ж бачу це я не говорю не лише про себе в
принципі про всіх своїх друзів з якими
от в Харкові бачили всі в тому всі
втомлені але ніхто не збирається
зупинятися іноді варто звичайно
перезавантажити сидіти в бік зробити
паузу нічого страшного в цьому немає
тому що ну це історія надовго завтра
Вона не завершиться
і щоранку як ти пишеш гарно в Фейсбуці
ми прокидаємося на день ближче до
перемоги ми так Росія